all right people this is a complicated
one on one hand
i loved diamond is unbreakable but now
that i've been through the first 21
episodes of this one
i think part 4 might have some
competition for my heart
and i say that because i blitzed through
this arc
i even think i ended up watching all 21
episodes that i'll be covering in this
video over the course of 24 hours
like this really held my attention like
none other before it
and what's more is this is an arc i can
honestly say
is unlike any of the other four and i
mean that in the best
possible way there's a clear attention
to detail and a design behind
it that gave it so much of an upside for
me so today i can't wait to share with
you all my very first impressions of
thoughts on and review for the fabled
fifth part of this manga epic
this is the brutally bloody the
heart-stoppingly compelling and the
relentlessly intense
jojo's bizarre adventure golden wizard
[Music]
as i mentioned before this week i'll be
covering the first half or the first 21
episodes of the fifth part to jojo's
bizarre adventure
golden winds set in 2001 italy it's the
first part to take place almost
immediately after the events of the
prior which was set during the year of
1999. however that's up to say that
there aren't some key differences right
off the bat with this one
obviously these surroundings are
gorgeous and faithful to its setting of
italy if any of you have taken the time
to look up anything about araki you'll
know that this guy
loves italy secondly and perhaps more
critically his characters throughout
this series have never looked
regular or normal for whatever that word
is worth in the beginning he would opt
to have characters with biceps bigger
than their character arc complete with
mr universe poses
and slowly over the course of the series
he replaced muscles with
clothing and there's nothing wrong with
that if not for
this part because holy crap okay so he
fills the world with regular people
wearing regular clothes and then
we see this guy wandering around town
casually
humans don't wear stuff like this or
maybe they do i mean i don't know i
haven't been outside since february of
2020.
jokes aside there's a considerable
amount of effort after going into
all of the character designs for the
story every one of these main characters
and i mean everyone
has a unique design boasting outlandish
clothing that would make any grandmother
shake their head in disapproval who
would have thought that when he drew
jotaro's
school uniform and hat which by the way
made sense when he first drew it but
over the course of the story began to
fuse with his head
who would have known that after seeing
all of that araki was actually
holding back it makes you wonder what
this guy's dreams are like
now i'm being light-hearted right now
and i think that's with good reason this
story is
easily the most brutal and graphic in
the series and that's coming from my
viewing of the anime
if you didn't see my review for part one
of this series it's obvious that a lot
of the stuff that gets left in the
chopping room floor is the gore from the
series and so you can well imagine what
the manga for this section looks like
and yet it starts out in a surprisingly
quiet way just following giorno giovanna
as he walks through his hometown of
naples italy special thanks to dragon
raja for sponsoring today's video dragon
raja is an open world mmo rpg that
features spectacular graphics for ios
and android mobile devices
brandishing all the polish of a aaa
console game you can carry around in
your pocket dragon raja also sports the
best character
designs i've ever seen on a mobile
device allowing you to create your own
ideal self in game plus they just got a
new update that added the brand new
class
phantom sound this class is clearly
designed around a particular theme
that being music and rhythm which from a
design point of view shows the level of
thought the team behind this game has
put
into it with this new update it also
added the new career of pet expert where
we can obtain new pets through daily
tasks
and pet breeding however the open world
is something i think you all can really
appreciate
standing in the streets can cause
traffic jams you can buy coffee and you
can dance
lastly but certainly not least february
27th is dragon raja's one year
anniversary where you can get fun prizes
including outfits and vehicles simply by
logging onto the game or their official
facebook page prizes will be available
until march 14th 2021 so
check out my link in the description to
download the unlimited fantasy mmorpg
dragon raja now here you can be whoever
and play
however and now back to the video
introduction to the new main character
while much more subtle than prior more
bombastic character introductions
this one is surprisingly effective which
is an appropriate take i think because
giorno is
a remarkably understated personality not
necessarily an understated character
because
well
[Music]
yeah walking past a considerable number
of crimes he immediately distinguishes
himself from jonathan
joseph jodorow and josuke who all would
have intervened in all of these
encounters
right from the get-go it paints a much
darker image of the world we are
entering into
and tells us a little bit about journal
as a result through a brief but telling
interaction as he helps some tourists
retrieve their formerly stolen wallet he
introduces us to his brand of justice
and morality
stealing from the two girls it's clear
that he only cares about what concerns
or affects him directly for the most
part however when he sees a small hungry
child he goes out of his way to buy him
some ice cream using the money he just
stole this small but character-defining
gesture while brief becomes part of a
much larger vision or motivation for
giorno
in this story who effectively when it
all boils down to it at the end of the
day
wants to acquire enough power to change
people's lives for the better and this
isn't the only instance where a rocky
changes up the formula on us either in
fact he does so at almost
every single turn in this story for
instance right after we learn that
giorno is a con man we cut to the
airport where he griffs and scams
tourists but also
where this little fellow arrives on the
scene
[Music]
after taking out a competing grifter in
lucca both giorno and koichi have a
brief but very fun encounter apparently
heaven's door of rohan's ability can
give you information that neither he
nor the person receiving the information
ever had like
being able to speak fluent italian so
automatically he becomes the most
powerful or valuable stand user in
existence i mean
in the last act they could have just
written into jodaro's head
i know what yoshikage kira's new name is
and we could have forgotten all of that
story
ain't that fun anyway once jono tries to
steal koichi's luggage the two of them
soon find out through various hiccups
that they are both stan
users with the main takeaways from this
conflict being jorno successfully steals
koichi's passport
and money has a stand that can create
life and deal damage to anyone that
would damage that life and koichi gained
some respect or favor from giorno as he
never went
all out against him proving to him that
he meant no harm there are a lot of
subtle things like that at play in the
story which make it i think
a much more adult version of a jojo's
story oh
and did i mention that jordan's father
is dio well
it is so that's a thing apparently
that's what koichi is there to
investigate upon to see what this
new young spawn of jojo's devil is up to
it is around this time the story where i
noticed that this tale is making a clear
effort to not only change a number of
key positions usually given to
particular personalities within the
story but
structurally once again iraqi decides to
shake things up completely
and in a direction i never thought it
would go while i thought diamond is
unbreakable serve to combine all of the
main narrative attributes of its three
older brother parrots exceptionally well
i personally thought that while the
structure of it was fun i also felt that
while better
than stardust crusader's episodic nature
diamond is unbreakable lacked direction
and a lot of pivotal moments for me
specifically now i want to clarify right
off the bat that that's not necessarily
a bad thing at all
a lot of people enjoy slice of life
hijinks and it worked remarkably
well for that story given how attached
to the characters i became and how
nostalgic i was towards the very end of
that story
however with all of that said and taking
nothing away from diamond is unbreakable
structurally speaking i think golden
wind is much more suited to my personal
sensibilities as a viewer everything
flows together
remarkably well every encounter makes
sense for the narrative and each episode
informs the next jorno wants to climb
the ranks of the mob
empire to gain power and influence over
his struggling town he meets bruno who
fights him after he learns to kill luca
this is a great mini fight by the way he
befriends bruno and then meets his boss
to try to get a job his boss tasks him
with holding this lighter and keeping
the light aflame for 24 hours koichi
causes trouble during this time
because giorno stole his passport they
get into trouble together and fight a
shadow man also a great fight by the way
jordan proves himself to the boss but he
was only doing so so he could get a
chance at assassinating him and he does
so and now he works with bruno
everything flows naturally into the next
main plot point all the while taking the
main cast and every supporting
character's motivations into
consideration
making for me golden wind a prime
example of and so therefore storytelling
while not sacrificing what brought it to
the dance in the first place
its creativity and artistic expression
while i know that what i'm about to say
is very english school major nerdy out
of all the action
and awesomeness these first few episodes
gave me my favorite part is easily when
koichi comes into journal's room at the
worst possible time
and it's my favorite because it's a
perfectly executed tension riser this
isn't happening just because
it's happening as a direct result of who
jorno is he
stole koichi's passport and so therefore
koichi is looking for his passport where
jorno is
and speaking of koichi something that
really caught my eye in particular
during this section also was once again
another first for the series
on top of this being the first with a
morally complex protagonist and the
first one to be directly related to dio
this is also the first sequel story
to not incorporate the prior cast in any
meaningful way apart from the first
couple of episodes in the first half
golden wind doesn't make any use of
koichi or jordaro's characters instead
opting to carry the entire story on the
backs of a brand new cast of colorful
characters
all the while pursuing a goal that ties
them all together take down the main
boss of the criminal syndicate that
they're working under that's never shown
his face
everything that's happened up until this
point has been set up entertaining setup
but set up nevertheless
from this point on we are entering the
main meat of this video and the plot
doesn't deviate from it once from here
on in and now with their old capo dead
and is fortunate to claim for themselves
they embark on a journey to the island
of capri
now as a larger team with journal in
their ranks
journey to capri something i've noticed
after completing half of this exciting
tale is that araki despite taking a much
more linear serialized approach
still employed many side stories
throughout this arc but not in the same
way he had done so in the past with arcs
like status crusaders and even diamond
is unbreakable to a large extent he
would often establish the goal and make
the means with which they achieve that
goal
known from the very beginning go to
egypt or find the killer etc however
with this one araki opted to create two
separate goals find out the identity of
the boss so they can kill him
and with the second one being discovered
during this particular section
and so while these side stories are
complete stories into and of themselves
in their own respect
they are still very much intrinsically
part of the original ongoing story
building upon material
and setup from the prior episodes for
instance this section begins on the back
of journal's assassination of bruno's
team capo
and as such is built upon the back of
that consequence bruno introduces jorno
to his team and over the course of this
adventure we come to learn about each of
these new characters until we become
intimately familiar with them heck i
even know all of their names and that's
really rare for someone like me
i mean we got bruno fugo mista leon and
narancia
a beautifully italian oh he said it was
so much confidence and still got
it wrong okay hello native italian
speaker can you please tell us how you
pronounce the name of that character in
jojo
naranja thank you despite right now only
being familiar with giorno and
maybe bruno to a lesser extent by the
time this story reached its midpoint i
found that i loved certain members of
this team more than the main character
journal and had a bond established with
all of them similarly to status
crusaders that put a heavy focus on the
side characters golden wind is in all
intents and purposes structured
identically to status crusaders without
the episodic monster of the week type
format through our first introduction to
the team it's clear that they don't
trust journal yet and each of them
fulfill a particular personality role
within the team
naranja is the youngest of the group
he's lovable and a bit of an airhead
fugo is effectively the opposite of
naranja being a bit abrasive and
something of a young prodigy leon is
sort of the tough guy of the group as a
former police officer he acts as the
detective of the team and finally we
have
mista i love mista he's got a great
energy around him and is possibly the
friendliest of the group and we learn
all about these key character elements
through the first scene and subsequent
scenes that follow
shortly after they hop into the boat
bound for capri with the goal of
claiming their former capo's fortune for
themselves and once the first bit of
trouble makes itself known to the group
right as they were sailing we get the
first hint as to how araki will be
structuring this story
this capri storyline is spent on two
major battles with one quick consequence
at the end that leads to the rest of the
story
again keeping in theme with every action
and forming the next this first battle
takes place on a yacht and through this
interaction we learn about leon's
backstory as a former police officer
wanting to make a greater change in the
world as well as his absolutely insanely
useful stand power that allows him to
relive certain scenes from different
perspectives in the past
once we overcome that gent of the ship
that turns out to be another ship within
the
same ship we land on capri and figure
out more about the character of mista
the most interesting element to both of
these encounters apart from allowing the
audience to get to know these characters
while also telling the story at the same
time is
how it establishes the differences
between everyone on the team through the
only character we know
giorno leon refuses to show his stand
ability in front of jorno proving to us
that he still doesn't trust him however
mista on the island doesn't have
remotely the same hang up
while on the surface miesta's stand
ability seems to be sort of cartoonish
and somewhat limited what he ends up
contributing to this story is some of
the most entertaining portions of it
everything from humor to sadness to edge
of your seat action
araki constructed this story to feel as
though everyone and anyone is capable of
meeting their end at any time
and they almost do on so so many
occasions
unlike all the other acts in the story
where characters good and bad would be
either incapacitated and later learn
their lesson or wander off into
obscurity
characters here in this part die and not
just die
they get brutally murdered by the good
guys alleviated somewhat by the colorful
and light-hearted interactions they
share with each other
these death scenes are more brutal than
any i've come across in the past
employing in this section with mista
some overdone encounters like a
chase on a truck that has made all the
more fun utilizing stand powers making
the circumstances feel so fresh and
enjoyable ending in a clint eastwood
type
standoff with uh this guy getting shot
in the head
real good
[Music]
that's a lot of damage it soon becomes
obvious that there are a number of
competing gangs looking for the same
fortune that they are and once they find
it
they too come across a gentleman in
possession of their next mission
to deliver the boss's daughter home for
bruno
now the new capo and giorno this is
ideal giving them an excuse to get close
to the boss in some capacity and
assassinate him this is their once in a
lifetime opportunity
and their team doesn't need to even know
about it nancy
versus small man once the boss's
daughter her name is trish by the way
arrives on the scene in
inconspicuous clothing as a janitor she
soon chucks to get up and throws on her
ridiculous outfit you know
to match the rest of the main characters
so as i guess not to draw attention
to herself also she's super high
maintenance and so forces naranzia to go
out and grab some supplies before they
make their way to the next stop
[Music]
this is one of the coolest ideas for a
fight i've come across in a long while
and certainly within jojo while the plot
slowly progresses towards a satisfying
finish
i hope i really enjoyed the narrative
decision made by iraqi during these
combat sequences
instead of isolating the lifespan of
particular fights to the pages of a
couple chapters or in the case of prior
arcs one episode
this story allows the fight to breathe
and explore all the possibilities their
powers offer them in tandem with this
setting they find themselves in this
battle with narancia and the guy that
can make himself small
is honestly brilliant not just for
showcasing that ancient's cool and
powerful stand but also because of the
worsening circumstances this shrinking
man stand power can do if enough time
elapses
in essence if naranzia can put away this
guy fast his chances would only get
worse and worse as he slowly but surely
shrinks into his own defeat
and let me tell you they do everything
with this premise with the elements used
in the ultimate defeat
of this shrinking men being equally
engaging and satisfying a lot of the
dialogue in prior fights would consist
of
immediate concerns brought forth by the
present battle however much of these
dialogue exchanges in golden wooden
concern themselves primarily with
motivations linked directly to the
broader story while also serving as a
great launching off point to inform us
the audience about the backstory of
characters like
to help build a bond with him and in the
case of the shrinking man we get to see
some of his past too
through which we learn about his
extended team of stand users on the
trail of bruno and giorno's team
he returns back to base and discovers
that bruno has received an email
directly from the boss
they need to go to the archaeological
park where there's a hidden key for a
vehicle that they can use to bring his
daughter home
they split the team one half with giorno
goes to get the key the other half with
bruno stays here and guards the daughter
of the boss
the archaeological park our time spent
at this archaeological park once again
gives us an opportunity to get to know a
new member of the squad all the while
building a new bond between the
characters
on screen and progressing the plot
during this section we come to learn
more about fugo with an iq of 152 he
managed to get into university
remarkably early however was kicked out
after he attacked a professor however as
has been the case with almost all of
these backstories including journals the
initial description of their past
doesn't seem to match up with how the
events
actually measured up when explored these
are all victims in some shape or form
with fugal particularly falling into
that category helping to explain how and
why he is so detached and aggressive
so much of the time the battle that
takes place is awesome with a focus of
course following fugo as he gets trapped
inside the mirror dimension
where have i seen that before but both
giorno and leon get some minor shine
during this outing too
as i'm editing this video it literally
just occurred to me that he's been
saying leone wrong the entire time
which is really funny because he only
started saying that first name because
he was too scared to say abakio i give
up
i give up i give up i've tried i tried
i'm sorry
and thanks to their combined effort and
some jaw-droppingly clever thinking on
behalf of jorno fugo's ridiculously
powerful stand gets a target to take out
however what was brought to my attention
during this section wasn't necessarily
all of that though it was knocking
around in there but what i really was
thinking about was how little of giorno
i've gotten to see
during this part of the story once the
setup in the initial episodes wrap up
journal feels very much like a stand-in
for the audience at times allowing for
exposition to be explained which again
is vital but
also feels like he's very much in
service equal part to the side
characters making the entire team
themselves feeling less like side
characters and more like main characters
and no
section made me feel this more than what
comes next after they discover the key
and the vehicle that it fits into battle
on the train
of the three major battles before this
climax i had to say that this is
easily my favorite part of the first
half and battled therein and it's not
even
remotely close with the others the level
of creativity and fun araki was clearly
having during this section
oozes from every frame and manga panel
taking place over the course of three
entire episodes the gang arrive at the
train station followed through the point
of view of the villains we saw in the
flashback earlier through small man
during this encounter araki spends
almost equal amounts of time with the
good guys and the bad guys making it
throughout feel as though any side could
potentially fail or come away with a win
here and the funny part is that giorno
barely participates with the rocky
instead opting to make full use of mista
and bruno's characters during this fight
sequence and
it's all the better for it when i say
that this fight has
everything i mean it there's some
mystery in the bad guys trying to
discover where the good guys have gone
to in the train they're in a tortoise by
the way there's some emotional
development for a character of pesci
that undergoes his own character arc
within these episodes there's a sense of
mourning on both sides after they think
that they've lost their respective
partners there's ludicrously engaging
action with some of the most creative
implementation of stand abilities in
this series
and it elevates every character directly
involved so much so that the two
characters of mista and bruno became my
two
favorite characters within this part of
the story elevating them both above
giorno for me
and that's just the mechanics within
this fight araki makes full use of the
location that this takes place in two
they kill a bunch of people trapped in a
train they fight on the roof they fight
on the sides they fight on the inside
and they even stop the train and finish
it outside
at numerous instances during this
encounter araki made full use of what
the audience was aware of
and what the characters weren't to help
build tension also
and he did this with both sides for
instance when one of the two brothers
starts to use his stand to age people up
we watch on as bruno's team try to piece
together what's going on
and watch them try to figure out how to
stop it conversely with the other side
of the action towards the very end bruno
needs to make full use of his stand
power in the most
incredible and literally
heart-stoppingly intense way he can
all the while we watch on as the fishing
rod wielding pesci struggles to figure
out where he went i could talk about
this section of the story and this
battle specifically for ages but in the
interest of time
these if nothing else are the episodes i
think that will sell you on part 5
if you are not a fan of it yet it's
honestly incredible and the best by far
in the series
delivering trish to her father i'm not
the biggest fan
of the next conflict that largely
concerns giorno not because i don't like
gerna but because the battle itself felt
sort of
small and anticlimactic perhaps because
it came immediately after my favorite
part of the story so
let's jump ahead to venice instead
there's another terrific section of the
story focusing on the ice battle with
jorno and mister that absolutely
solidified mister as my second favorite
character in the story it has some
incredible animation and let me just
tell you this entire part that i've
watched so far
is top to bottom gorgeous with some
truly brilliant animated moments
on the topic of mista i adore his
personality and his tenacity during this
combat sequence and his little sex
pistols are
always a treat the drama in this fight
is fittingly high and the action
provided was
thrilling probably my second favorite
fight along with narancia's fight
earlier
also it might very well have the best
ending of all the fights i've seen
[Music]
one rather important critique i have for
this section however is
perhaps how it handled the character of
trish as the daughter of the boss and
the package that they've had to deliver
over the course of this story the only
thing
she's really contributed to it have been
some small few
snarky comments as well as some comedic
fanservice during the midpoint which i
never really enjoy it's not my thing
given how much time has been spent with
this team i would have liked to have
cared a bit more about trish
at all by the time she ultimately got
delivered to her father
as she's taken up the elevator to meet
her long-lost familial patriarch she
finally starts to show glimpses of
character and uncertainty through the
rough and brash exterior she's putting
up throughout this trip
this is great but what would have been
much more effective is having this sort
of exposition earlier on in the trip
that way tension could potentially build
more effectively on their way to the
tower and heck maybe it might even give
more of a motivation to bruno maybe he
could have been the one to talk her into
it and once things inevitably go awry
once they get to the island in venice
there could have been more of a reason
for him to blame himself and take
personal responsibility for her capture
and possible death i thought trish
offered the opportunity to be a rich
character with tons to offer the
narrative in order to up the stakes
however instead she came across much
more like a damsel in distress or
possibly more accurately a mcguffin or
plot device used to forward the
narrative to the midpoint climax like
she ultimately did
i hope that by the time i get around to
the rest of the second half she plays a
much larger role that offers more to the
story than a mute animal could otherwise
have achieved one thing
i want to say also about the big bad of
this arc is that while i appreciate they
wanted to create an insurmountable or
intimidating force to overcome
using their powers in creative ways i
sort of feel as though araki has gone to
the time manipulation well
one too many times during these stories
i mean since stands have been introduced
the big bad of the ark has
always had on some level time
manipulation abilities
and after giving it some thought i've
grown to understand why
to some extent it's incredibly powerful
realistically when you're creating a
villain there are three schools of
thought i think
firstly there's making your antagonist
impossibly powerful like dio in some
respects and certainly like the boss
from this part 5.
the goal of these villains is not to be
relatable or likable but instead to
provide a wall for which
the good guys are to overcome secondly
there's the opposite of what i just
demonstrated a villain to be and that's
being weaker than the hero only to try
his best to get more powerful and
eventually become that threat
these first two are the most common and
to be honest both have their ups and
down sides characters like dio can feel
less like characters and more like walls
of power to overcome
furthermore they also have a tendency to
get predictable and sort of boring if
you over rely on that archetype too
often
the weaker villain has the opposite
problem in that they are too relatable
people in general love to cheer for the
underdog tenaciously fighting against
all odds and so putting your protagonist
into a more powerful position
prior means you need to make certain
that your hero is incredibly likable to
your reader or viewer in order for them
to cheer for them
alternatively then there's the third
option which iraqi decided to opt for
during diamond is unbreakable story with
kira and kira ended up being my favorite
antagonist out of this series
instead of having a villain that is
obviously weaker or stronger than josuke
he instead decided to make him a
compliment to josuke sort of like the
other side of a coin if you will i
thought kira was a brilliant foil for
josuke and the most ideal candidate
among the jojo villains for that very
reason and he didn't need time powers
either
proven by him not using them once during
his fight with josuke and only using
them in the lead up to the battle
now obviously there are ways of screwing
that option up too seen all too well in
marvel films where the superheroes like
iron man captain america ant-man doctor
strange and black panther even
all seem to face off against evil
versions of themselves
instead of flipping the power set they
flip the personality behind the power
which isn't always bad but over the
course of a series can become formulaic
which i think is jojo's problem right
now with this time manipulation ability
while i did love this scene with bruno
and giorno in the gloomy hideout
confronting the big boss for the very
first time
i couldn't help but feel a little
underwhelmed when i discovered that ooh
look hits time powers again when the
powers of this dude exist that could
have served as a much more of an
interesting match-up against
jordano's power specifically that we
never really got to see
jordan can give life and he can
technically take it away
now that is all obviously hinging on the
idea that giorno is the main character
and judging by the way this is going it
seems to be much more of an ensemble
cast
rather than a particularly focused
protagonistic story so we'll see how
things go
anyways and so now with this big boss
man after putting a hit out on the
entire team we'll see how this entire
story decides to progress
anyways these are just my immediate
thoughts on half of golden wind and next
week i'll be sharing my thoughts with
how the entire story felt for me as well
as analyzing its ending
in detail next week will be my last jojo
video until more material becomes
available to review and after that i've
got a couple of videos i've wanted for a
while and then
a new series begins in april
[Music]
you